[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: One of the
driving principles
of the mobile marketplace is
that users want new-- new apps,
new updates, new content.
In fact, over 60%
of the users who
go on to digital marketplaces
do so because they
want to try something new.
While this is fantastic
for user acquisition,
this presents a problem
for user retention.
Because if you are not
keeping the user's attention,
they will quickly be looking
for something that will.
In this episode, we will learn
how to create a good retention
strategy.
Ready?
Let's get started.
The key to effective
user retention
can be broken down into
three things-- one,
understand user's
behavior in your app; two,
identify roadblocks
to retention; three,
use tactics and tools
to re-engage users.
Now of course,
all of this starts
with understanding your users.
If you don't understand what
they want, how they act,
or their opinions, you can't
really craft a strategy
on how to keep them happy.
The good news is
that Google Analytics
has a set of tools to
give you insight here.
First, check out your
Cohort Analysis report.
Why?
Because Cohort Analysis
is a powerful report that
allows you to measure
and compare users
based on their specific customer
journey-- for example what
pages they visit, what
they do, how they behave
at each stage, et cetera.
So you can measure the impact
of your marketing campaigns
on specific days, see
how effective they
are in generating loyal
users, and compare
which campaign performed best.
Another good report
is Active Users.
Find out how your users
interact with your app over time
so you can better
understand why they may
be staying in or leaving it.
It displays your
one-day active users up
to 30-days active users
next to each other.
This helps you answer some
important questions regarding
your user retention.
For example, if your
30-day active number
is much higher than the
one-day active number,
most users are not
coming to your app
more than once during
a 30-day period.
This can indicate that you need
to add fresh content on a more
regular basis.
And maybe you need
to re-engage users
through marketing campaigns
and notifications.
The third report
is about recency.
This report shows how much time
passed between app sessions.
You might discover users who
only open your app once a week.
Once you identify users
that engage with your app
infrequently, you
need to figure out
how to re-engage that audience.
You could send push
notifications to those users
after three days to
remind them about the app.
You could even tailor the
message to include incentives.
A gaming app, for
example, might want
to send a push notification with
an offer of a free in-app tool
to users who haven't
opened the app in a while.
Now that you have an
understanding of your users,
you can start thinking about
what their experience is like
and get visibility
into what roadblocks
they are encountering
in your app.
Here are three
basic ways that will
help you get this information.
Screen tracking
will help you learn
where users spend their time.
For example, if each level of
a game uses a different screen,
you could track what
percentage of people
pass through each level.
If there's a level that has
a massive user drop-off,
that may indicate that there
is a technical issue associated
with that level.
Or it is just too hard.
Monitor your
behavioral flow report.
It takes your screen
tracking, event tracking,
and combines it in
a visual user flow.
Lastly, use the Crash and
Exceptions report to identify
possible roadblocks.
You could break data out by
app version, operating system,
and device brand so
you could evaluate
your app's technical performance
in different environments.
Want to take it
one step further?
Find out how much
crashes are costing you.
You could do this by creating
two segments, one for sessions
with crashes and other without.
Then compare the conversion
rates and the average order
value to see if these
metrics are lower
in the sessions with crashes.
Now that you've got
all the basics down,
the final step is building an
effective re-engagement button
for your users.
This varies between apps.
But the tools we covered
today will help you
think in the right direction.
Do me a favor.
Stop spending money
on apps installs
if you don't have a
retention strategy.
It's like the dude that
sells tomatoes at a loss
and tells his friend
that he's going
to compensate on it by volume.
[LAUGHTER]
Game monetization today is more
challenging and sophisticated
than it used to be.
A good monetization
strategy depends
on your retention strategy.
You need to understand
your user's behavior,
identify roadblocks, and
use tactics and tools
to re-engage with your users.
On the next episode,
we will learn
how to use in-app purchase house
ads as part of our strategy
to increase revenue.
Until next time,
eat your vegetables
and listen to your partners.
[MUSIC PLAYING]